KEITH DANEKIND: Hi,
I'm Keith Danekind,
and I'm a customer engineer
on the Apigee team.
Today I want to
show you how Apigee
can help modernize a legacy
application to enable
new digital experiences.
We'll look at a
demo where I'm going
to move a service from a
legacy environment to the cloud
without disruption and add
a bunch of other benefits
along the way.
Here's a diagram that
describes the problem
I'm trying to solve.
There's a service running
in the legacy environment,
and I'd like to move
it into Google Cloud.
I'd like to do this without
disrupting the existing
applications and establish
a pattern that I can
use for moving future services.
I'll start by building
a facade in Apigee.
I'll make well-designed
REST services that
have consistent
interfaces and security,
and I'll map those to
the back-end services.
I'll map the basic
CRUD operations--
Create, Read, Update,
and Delete-- to the HTTP
verbs POST, GET,
PUT, and DELETE.
I'll use Apigee's routing
features to route traffic
to the right back-end
services, and I'll
use Apigee to manage API
keys for each application
and create policies in Apigee
to manage the flow of traffic.
Here's the goals I
have for my project.
First, I want to move
the legacy service
to the cloud with no downtime.
I want to start by testing
the cloud service by routing
10% of the traffic to the
cloud, make sure everything's
working the right way.
I want to get visibility
into which applications
are using the service.
Today there's a
single URL, and we've
got some logs and
things like that,
but I don't know which
application is sending
in traffic specifically.
I'll add API keys in
Apigee that'll identify
individual applications.
I want to add some rate limits
to protect the services.
We don't want one
application calling too much.
We'll add call quotas based
on the partner relationship,
so different partners
get different quotas.
I want to remove some sensitive
internal data from the partner
applications.
I need to add support
for XML-formatted data
to support some of
the legacy clients.
If they request XML,
we'll return it.
I want to make it easy to
onboard new applications
in the future and get ready
for the hundreds of partner
applications I know are coming.
And throughout all
of this, I want
to establish a
reference architecture
so that this can be the pattern
for moving future services.
Let's look at a demo and see
how to build this in Apigee.
Here in Apigee, I've configured
two target endpoints,
one for each of the
different back-end systems,
the legacy system
and the cloud system.
I also have a URL
here where it will
be listening for traffic
to come in and be
routed through Apigee.
This is where I manage the
request and response flow.
I'll put different
policies in here
to affect how the traffic flows.
The first one checks
for an API key.
Next is a Spike Arrest to
prevent too much traffic
from coming in.
Then there's a
business-related quota
that's going to limit
the number of calls
depending on who's calling.
The next two are what we're
going to use specifically
for routing.
Apigee has a key value
map, and inside of there I
store important values.
I've put a probability
in there that I'm
going to use to determine how
much traffic goes to the cloud
and how much goes to
the legacy system.
So this looks up
that value, and then
we're going to have some
JavaScript in here to randomly
set a flag, and that
flag will determine
whether we get routed to the
cloud or the legacy system.
Let's look at how that works.
In this JavaScript
policy, we see there's
some code referenced here.
So here's our code for
generating a random number
and then checking to see
if it's past the threshold
and setting a flag
to true if it is.
So testGroup will be set to
true if we're in the test group.
Down here we have
some route rules.
Route rules let us configure
where the traffic should
be routed in Apigee.
You can have multiple
different back ends,
and you can route to different
ones using some of these rules.
I've got two back-end
systems in here.
I have the cloud system
and the legacy system.
If the condition
testGroup equals to true,
this rule will be
true and we'll be
routed to the cloud back end.
That gives us a 10%
chance, in this case,
of being routed to cloud.
There are a few more
goals I had for this,
and we can see those
on the response side.
One goal was to
remove sensitive data,
so there's a particular field in
there that I want to take out.
I've got some JavaScript in
here to remove a sales group,
so there's a particular
field called SalesGroup.
I want to delete that from
the JSON that comes back.
If there's an accept
header on the request
equal to application/XML,
this policy will fire,
and it'll convert
from JSON to XML
and return the
data in XML format
to those clients who need it.
I can build a custom
report in Apigee
to see how much traffic is
going to the legacy environment
and how much is
going to the cloud.
I can click through on each
metric and get more details.
This shows me traffic from
each of the applications,
and I get an idea
of who's sending
the traffic into the system.
One of the other
goals was to make it
easy to onboard new partners.
I've created a developer
portal in Apigee,
and this provides
complete self-service
for people who want to
write applications using
the APIs that I've provided.
They can come in here.
They can read documentation
about how the APIs work.
They can try them
out, and they can
sign up and get credentials.
That was a quick
demo about how we
might use Apigee to
modernize a legacy service
and move it up to the cloud,
and add a bunch of stuff
along the way.
Thanks for watching today.
[MUSIC PLAYING]